[Musique]
je m'appelle bernard richard j'ai 25 ans
je suis le créateur la société bernard
richard objets de luxe
je réalise annuellement un chiffre
d'affaires de 1 milliard 250 millions de
centimes
[Applaudissements]
vous avez fait les normes
prenez tout rien et où j'ai rien près
des taux uniquement l'école d'horlogerie
pendant deux ans et
est ce que vous avez comme diplôme
certificat d'études allô oui maman c'est
vers l'art à l'appareil j'arrive dans 5
minutes rien eu de spécial
ok bon bah j'arrive en bas depuis il a
plutôt l'air d'être un loubard que la
chef d'entreprise c'est juste il avait
peut-être une barre mais il a les pieds
sur la terre on accepte très très bien
parce que les gens qui sont des chefs
d'entreprise aiment avoir affaire à des
jeunes
je pense qu'ils auraient aimé être comme
lui en retravaillant ce tous les deux
vous ressemblez pas un oui mais qui
n'empêche pas qu'on travaille ensemble
qu'est ce qui détonne
vous lui je sais pas du tout c'est
peut-être lui sinon ça peut être
complémentaire
nous faisons des objets usuels qui sont
traités dans l'ue que c'est à dire entre
ans
par exemple le rasoir et l'idée m'est
venue en rasant le matin avec un rasoir
en plastique et en me disant il faut
faire la même chose mais en très cher
puisqu'il ya la clientèle et le matin
vous vous rasez en plastique pendant le
jeu me rase avec un rasoir en plastique
[Musique]
m
je vends aux gens très riches des
français
quelques français mais ça devient
beaucoup d'étrangers oui deux guides
odeurs d'européens beaucoup d'arabes
beaucoup beaucoup d'arabes
je vend du vent c'est ce qu'il faut
c'est vendu du vent faut vendre
n'importe quoi du moment que ça a
demandé
mon produit se vend très bien des
conneries très cher c'est l'argent qui
vous excite c'est pas tellement l'argent
qui m'excite c'est la réussite unique -
la russie l'argent vient après qu'est ce
que ça veut dire les réussites voir mon
nom dans les temps les plus belles est
[Musique]
ce que vous savez pas remis en verlan
oui oui oui vraiment je sais que parler
en leur nom ça vous plaît j'aime bien
oui souvent devant les clients je le
fais comme ça ne comprennent pas et
j'arrive un petit peu à tirer mon
épingle du jeu il ya pas de problème la
ferraille dans le que ça je vais en
relais pas mon rôle traduction la sphère
est dans le sac je n'en parlais mon père
alors mon rêve c'est un petit rêve
secret enfin c'est de pouvoir fabriquer
des voitures de luxe et les fourriers
aux clients j'ai déjà dans les pays
arabes et tout puisque j'ai déjà cette
clientèle donc je peux le revendre autre
chose c'est la première bagnols que vous
avez à la rentrée non j'avais une
porsche turbo l'année dernière
j'ai vendu parce que c'était un petit
peu trop pour les clients quelqu'un qui
a démarré il ya deux ans et qui n'a pas
une longue expérience derrière lui et
donc rouler tout de suite en porsche
turbo c'est un petit peu trop donc je
préfère rouler en rangeant moeurs et du
commun
[Musique]
oh
je suis djamel nasser mais en fait je
suis président du conseil
d'administration de la société
californienne bureau présidente du
conseil des ministres à ce que c'est ça
oui vous avez une carte de visite
ah oui absolument oui vous avez créé ça
tout seul ah non j'ai pas créer la
société tout seul california burke
secret avec un groupe d'amis à l'origine
et on a foncé pour créer cette société
vous allez me convient ah bon on a mis
dix mille francs chacun et les banques
les banques non quand vous voyez un
banquier pour la première fois et qui
vous met gentiment dehors vous n'avez
plus envie de revoir les banques alors
il faut se débrouiller tout seul et
comment vous il faut tout faire soi même
vous avez tous construits tout construit
du carrelage à l'électricité la pose des
vitres pas tout et matériel à vannes
matériel celui de matériels performants
1 je pense il est made in usa et tout
est électronique ici mon rêve 500 unités
california burke sur toute la france
[Musique]
vous êtes question ici vous souhaitez
c'est réactionnaire en même temps
actionnaire qu'est ce que ça fait d'être
actionnaire ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de
choses parce que je pense
enfin si j'étais pas le sonneur je pense
pas que j'aurais travaillé ici pendant
deux ans parce que je pense pas que
caissière ce soit un métier d'avenir et
j'aurai beau c'est peut-être un mois ou
deux pour me dépanner
j'avais des problèmes d'argent mais
quand on travaille pour soi je crois que
on a envie de rester et vous avez mis
combien dans la société
dix mille francs
couture pas assez
un jus d'orange mais là c'est pas
annoncer pas pareil quand on travaille
pour soi c'est pas la même chose
qu'est ce qui change qu'est ce qui
change
ben quand on voit défiler plein plein de
clients et puis qu'on sait que c'est nos
clients c'est ça qui fait la différence
en dise que dans dans un autre magasin
c'est pas mes clients c'est les clients
du patron bonjour je m'appelle bonne can
code j'ai 25 ans ce magasin il
m'appartient j'y fais dès qu'elles sont
et je ferai tout pour réussir
j'ai créé ma petite boîte parce que je
j'étais engagé dans une grosse société
vous savez sur l'assaut public et je
faisais des projets sur projet qui
terminait dans les tiroirs des
directeurs je me suis dit bon ba 25 ans
il faut que je fasse mes preuves parce
que personne n'a confiance en moi et je
suis partie de moi même j'ai emprunté 30
mille francs auprès d'une banque
et je fais un coup de poker et votre
banquier par exemple qu'est ce qu'il a
dit quand il vous a vu arriver les télés
voir quels sont ceux ça me manque et je
vais changer les lois qu'elles sont mais
j'ai ouvert mes malades et
je vais montrer vacation tous les côtés
tout l'avant keriolet ce que je voulais
c'était un peu l'effet que je voulais
faire mais je me suis assis je dis voilà
monsieur j'ai cinq mythes qu'elles sont
en commande après le salon du vêtement
qu'est ce que vous faites est le gars
m'a dit après discussion et discussions
on peut vous accorder à découvrir de 50
mille francs mais sans enthousiasme
non c'est à ce moment là je mange avons
contacté dix minutes après et je lui ai
dit moi je ne travaille pas avec des
gens sans enthousiasme ce que je veux
c'est vraiment travailler avec des gens
qui me font confiance
j'avale oh oui bonjour cannes code ça
c'était belichick vous m'avez téléphoné
ce matin
effectivement vous avez les coups de
poker en un coup de poker moi je
voudrais que toute ma vie c'est un coup
de poker je crois que le jour du moment
ce serait aussi un coup de poker
le tissu liberty et berti toussaint pour
50 ou 100 % coton alors quand vous avez
c'est vraiment la seule du canton le cap
de l'exclusivité porteront ce dont je
vous avais parlé en exclusivité pour re
belichick
ça va faire mal heures tout le monde
vraiment superbe et vous forcez malgré
les crises mais ça vous fait pas peur on
va vous montrer à la crise ça me donne
envie de dial et de dépenser toutes les
portes les gens sont dans leurs
problèmes et moi je passe à travers
leurs petits problèmes mais ce sera
quelque chose qui me black line tout à
fait vous demander quels sont exactement
dès leur taille large comme vous renier
ses enfants par mois et quand vous
faites convives
j'emprunte pour vivre aujourd'hui pour
développer mon entreprise et beaucoup de
dettes 3 30 40 mille francs
mais par contre au niveau de
l'entreprise en elle même j'ai 40
battant de dette
moi mon rêve c'est de voir tout le monde
dans la veille en caleçon
[Musique]